saki said it's unfair and absurd that
companies would raise costs for
consumers due to higher taxes wow it is
absolutely unfair somebody needs to pay
attention to their economy class or math
class profit and law students so let me
read this to you
on what she said this is a uh foundation
for economic education article ein rand
famously quipped you can avoid reality
but you cannot avoid the consequences of
avoiding reality let me say that one
more time you can avoid reality but you
cannot avoid the consequences of
avoiding reality at a monday press
conference saki was confronted by
journalists citing data showing that
house democrats
proposed tax increases would violate
president biden's pledge not to raise
taxes on anyone earning less than four
hundred thousand dollars in particular
multiple studies have shown that the
proposed increase in corporate tax rate
from 21 to 26 and a half will lead to
lower wages for workers and higher
consumer prices saki responded to the
journalists query by downplaying the
potential pass along cost and simply
declaring them immoral there are some
who argue that in the past companies
have passed on the cause to consumer
saki said we feel that's unfair and
absurd that the american people will not
stand for that danielle thoughts
oh i'm sorry really seriously no she
really said this this is not uh onion
article this is a real article but
there's there's nothing to be said about
it i mean you're not
businesses are not in business to be
charities yeah they're 501cs if they're
charities
and that's not that's what china has
done to its entire tutoring sector
educational sector it has made them all
into non-profits and lo and behold what
happened to them overnight they went out
of business
so for her to
operate under that assumption when we
have a real-time example of what happens
when when
the government effectively says you are
a not-for-profit institution it's just
it's it's asinine sorry that was
probably not a very polite word but it
is just that it's a lot better than last
night though i mean it is true yes last
night it was a bit why is she saying
these
job is to get up there and do a spin job
and make the president look good it's
not like she's voicing her own opinion
is she or is she
speculating this is what the president
like who is calling her you're correct
it is definitely her job um
unfortunately biden couldn't articulate
his thoughts if he tried i didn't say
that out loud but but you're right it is
her job to sell don't get on whatever is
being
whatever the administration is trying to
peddle it's her job to sell it's just
like janet yellen trying to say that 140
countries or however many countries that
she's talking about need to raise the
minimum corporate tax i tell you one
thing though i don't mind the idea of a
minimum corporate tax of a floor because
every time congress gets involved with
the tax code
there's one beneficiary and only one
beneficiary and that's the cpa community
because all they do is make the damn tax
code more complicated which means you
have to pay your cpa more to find the
loopholes to get out of paying taxes
because that's what companies do that's
what wealthy people do if you put a
floor if you just say it's
an alternative minimum tax for a company
if you're amazon.com and you're making
billions and billions and billions and
billions of dollars and you don't pay
any taxes there's something wrong with
that so i'm i'm good with this it's a
flat tax for corporations like a flat
tax exactly exactly what would the floor
be 15 what's the number i mean 15 is a
very reasonable number and we'd get a
hell of a lot more tax revenue if we did
something like that wasn't that what the
whole
idea was that they were trying to
uh globally that's fine you're always
going to have no united united states
terrible idea buddy you don't want that
to be globally no i'm saying but that's
what you propose no yes she did but you
do not want all countries in the world
to have the same advantage they won't
all agree you will you will always know
where you want that because there's no
communication with them i think it was
the opportunity
but it doesn't matter there are going to
be there are always going to be
countries that look at such
global moves as great opportunities to
take market share and become a tax haven
period
so you'll never get all countries to
agree to it there will there's always if
it's not dublin it'll it'll be whoever
dublin's successor is for americans to
put their headquarters there will always
be
good they're smart for not doing that
their wives are not doing that like
imagine you're forced to only be with
one person
like your chosen there's only one person
you can be with you would be miserable
marriage though but no no no you're
forced to marriage is a choice right
you're forced you don't you're not
forced to get married you choose to get
married in this situation if everybody's
taxes are the same across the world
you're forced this is it you ain't got
another mars to go to or you know moon
to go to build a big ship you know build
a business for yourself this is it for
you right and i mean if you look at
china they're giving tax breaks to
industries that they want to succeed the
semiconductor industry they're not
giving tax breaks to real estate
companies at all but they are giving tax
breaks to industries that they want to
build
internally so that they're less reliant
on imports and over here in the united
states we're talking about jacket up to
the corporate tax rate
we're just going about this the wrong
way we really are going about it the
wrong way and
her points are just idiotic i think saki
missed it you know you go deep and you
really give everyone the depth behind it
but there is things that are just so
simple it was in front of her like
businesses are not going to do this i'll
give you a tale of two cities grubhub
and doordash grubhub contract did not
let you price delivery different from
pickup or in so if you want to use
grubhub your contract said the price had
to be the same for everybody whereas
doordash says well wait a minute i'm
going to charge you 30 bucks if you want
to put a three dollar service fee or
something on that
it's going to be delivered great well
two years later
grubhub is suffering and nobody wants to
work with grubhub none of the none of
the restaurants wanna work or grubhub
you're killing me you take thirty
percent to deliver i can't even put a
service fee on it because your control
you're controlling my pricing which is
basically what pizzagate was saying
price control doordash says you wanna
put a service fee on there to cover
thirty 30 fine i just want to i just
want to deliver it hot for people that
love your your food doordash
is 50 market share three years ago they
were 16 three years ago three years ago
grubhub was 50 market share and they're
16 today the two numbers complete
opposite complete opposite good for them
it's fantastic for doordash and so it's
called computing that's that's great
that's some awful we're supposed to be
competitors in a capitalistic right
economy so not only does saki not have a
calculator she obviously doesn't have
internet access because this has been
the story first but tom this is another
opportunity of divide and conquer blame
every divide pin employer against
employee exactly constantly pin them
against each other and tell them it's
the employer's fault so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you